حان وقت العشاء عند الميل عند الذراعين في
شمال غرب لندن ،
وتأتي الطلبات كثيفة وسريعة
على الرغم من كونها مشغولة ،
غالبًا ما تحتوي حانة الملك الخضراء هذه على بقايا الطعام التي اعتادوا التخلص منها ،
ولكن منذ الشراكة مع تطبيق نفايات الطعام
أصبحوا قادرين على البيع  يوجد في أوروبا
عدد قليل من تطبيقات الطعام التي تكافح من
أجل قصاصات olio karma التي لا تهدر وهي
جيدة جدًا لاستخدامها ،
هذا الأخير هو رائد في المجال الذي
تأسس في عام 2016 ويقع مقره في الدنمارك
مع انتشار هائل يعمل في 16
دولة عبر أوروبا والولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
كندا تخدم حوالي 40 مليون مستخدم
ماتالوجا هو الرئيس التنفيذي بعد المشاركة في تأسيس
تطبيق للياقة البدنية تم بيعه لشركة Under
Armor مقابل 85 مليون دولار ،
وانضمت luca جيدًا إلى الحد الذي لا يمكن أن تذهب إليه عن طريق الصدفة عندما
رأيت لأول مرة أه
جيد جدًا لدرجة أنني كنت في  الحافلة
خارج كوبنهاغن والمرأة
التي بجواري أظهرتها لي على هاتفها ،
لقد بدأنا للتو في
الدردشة وأنا فقط أحببت على الفور
المفهوم الذي كان في الغالب مجرد
حدس في البداية لم أكن أعرف الكثير
عن الطعام  نفايات ، لذلك ذهبت إلى المنزل
لإجراء بحث وصُدمت تمامًا
لأنك تعلم على الرغم من أنني
أحترم كثيرًا الطعام ، إلا أنني لم
أدرك حقًا أنها كانت مشكلة مناخية كبيرة
، إلا أن الجانب الأكثر تحديًا
في هذا العمل هو العثور على
مطاعم للشراكة  مع العملاء أو العثور عليهم
، هل هي المنافسة ،
أعتقد أن أكبر اختناق لدينا حتى
الآن هو العثور على شركاء بسرعة
كافية آه لأننا رأينا أن
هناك طلبًا كبيرًا على هذا ، لذا
يجد الكثير من المستخدمين هذا الأمر
جذابًا ، ما هو الدرس الأكبر
أنك تعلمت إدارة هذه الشركة
عندما بدأنا في العديد من بلداننا ،
لم نشهد حدوث حركة كبيرة لإهدار الطعام
بالفعل في بعض
الأشياء ولكن في الكثير من
البلدان ساعدنا في بدء
ذلك وأعتقد أنه
يستغرق الأمر وقتًا طويلاً
لإشراك الجميع في
الرسالة التي تعرفها إذا كنا جادين
بشأن تغير المناخ ، وعلينا أيضًا أن
نفكر بشكل مختلف في
طعامنا وعلينا أن  تأمروا بهذه العادات